so yeah thanks for quick introduction
another quick introduction so Who am and
why you should be listening to me
so I'm from Kiev Ukraine originally I've
been using Python since 2001 writing
called professionally since 2002 I
worked a lot from visual effects than
did an MBA then somehow transition to
data science like some of you here
data science of course the new field so
currently I'm heading a data science
team at a mobile gaming company Logan so
how many of you are using Jupiter
notebooks okay oh that's kind of obvious
otherwise you probably wouldn't be at
this talk and in my experience I've seen
a lot of Jupiter notebooks so before
coming to Berlin and leading this data
science team at Google I was the another
data science team at another mobile
gaming company in London and I've seen
some really horrible looking bison
notebooks to be honest half of them were
my own notebooks so how did we get here
and why it's important and what we can
do about it that's actually the topics
of this talk why we end up with the PI
messy Python notebooks well partially
it's because this magical beasts data
scientists is a combination of part-time
engineer scientists and maybe a business
person so we're not some of us a lot of
people in data science are not coming
from software engineering background of
course and that's great that's what
makes this community so unique and so
diverse but it also creates some
problems
another problem with data science
community is it's so new so when I also
looking at some books on data science
for instance this is a quarter from a
data science in Python book in a
nutshell coding is telling a computer to
do something using a language it can
distance so that's the level where some
of those instructionally data science
books are at it's really targeting
people who just have no clue and try to
figure out how to you how to use this
code thing another part of the problem
is currently the number of data
scientists is probably doubling every
two or three years I'd say which means
that at any point in time half of the
data scientists are
less than two or three years of work
experience overall and this of course
also challenge yesterday I was in this
room and somebody made a comment that
generally data scientists don't really
write a good code not as good as data
engineers I actually want to say that I
disagree with that
controlling four years of work
experience I hope that is actually it's
not the case because actually data
scientists are focused on doing a
specific thing they probably more
focused on actually doing that thing and
don't have as much time thinking about
abstractions and building some more
complex things and then worry too much
about some of those things that make a
code completely unreadable if you
actually don't have a lot of experience
so I read a quote somewhere that I do to
call software engineer masters
complexity for the first two years of
your career and then the next 20 years
spends mastering art of simplicity so
first you get super excited about object
orientation so you write class
everywhere then you discover functional
programmer programming you switch
everything to functions then you
discover decorators you start decorating
everything then you discover meta
programming so you write code that will
generate another code or maybe you start
inventing a language so you don't
actually need to write a programming
code you can define everything using
some higher level of abstraction and
then after five maybe ten years to
figure out that actually there's only
three operators in programming it's
assignment its if statement and it's a
loop and everything else you just kind
of put on top to make those three by six
construct constructs more manageable so
anyway another reason why we end up with
a message appear in notebooks is because
the typical answer is that it's not
going to production anyway I'm just
playing around I'm just doing research
therefore who cares that my code is
messy and that's fundamentally wrong I
believe because any fool can write code
that computer can understand good
programmers write code that humans can
understand I'm canned back said that and
that's of course very true for jupiter
notebooks jupiter notebooks are written
not from computer to consume but
actually for other people to read and
understand so in my opinion is arguably
even more important to clean your code
clean inside the jupiter notebook
in some software systems and then of
course like you write something messy it
works so you don't care but then of
course it doesn't end there
there is always a follow-up questions
and then you can start drilling deeper
into data and then a product manager or
whoever may be a supervisor comes and
with tons more questions they actually
have to reuse your code multiple times
so keeping your code clean of course is
super important so hopefully I convinced
you that actually keeping a notebook in
the Jupiter messy is not a good thing
and even so it doesn't go to production
maybe from however sometimes it does
we still need to write code that is
clean so first community that we can
borrow a lot of knowledge from is of
course software engineering community
those guys were thinking about how to
write clean code for decades
specifically Robert C Martin also known
as Uncle Bob popularized the pin code
movement and such a lot about how to do
that so first of all what is clean code
before we figure out how to write clean
code let's think about what actually is
a clean code pleasently graceful and
stylish in appearance or manner well and
that's a guy who actually invented C++
oh my god
clean code reads like a well written
prose that's actually sounds pretty cool
each routine turns out to be pretty much
what you expected so it's the surprise
minimization thing I think it's actually
treason it's working but how do you
actually do it there are also some
advices how to do it on the high level
on some philosophical level I like this
one first make it work then make it
right then make it fast and small run
all tests contain no duplicate code
express all ideas minimizes classes and
methods and this one by Uncle Bob Martin
basically general rule is you try to
leave the campground cleaner than you
found it it's actually applied from Boy
Scout rule of America partly but it
actually applies very well to code so
every time you try to improve the code
once you read somebody else code until
visiting it you always can find that
few things how to refactor it of course
the refactor code unit tests and that's
also one the reasons why we have a lot
of ugly code also come back so that I'm
not a great programmer I'm just a good
programmer with great heads so how do I
actually can develop those better habits
what we can do to develop those habits
let's first talk about naming things as
fill call to such famous thing there are
only two hard problems in computer
science cache invalidation and naming
things and for my experience cache
invalidation is actually not too hard
but naming things of course is a couple
of years ago when I was doing my MBA and
I did all sorts of business acrosses and
I really missed coding I started
programming objective-c and in the
beginning it was pretty horrible the
learning curve was quite steep I don't
know who ever kind of touch Objective C
and some shaping for a couple of people
so it's when you look at it it looks
pretty horrible but after a while I
really start appreciating it and so then
I found that languages very beautiful
it's super verbose so they really like
really long descriptive names actually
learned how to write a good Python code
by learning Objective C more so than
maybe for last five years when I was
just using Python so in Python modules
quite a lot you will find that there are
very short names it's like tendency to
make everything very small and sometimes
actually hurts us so long descriptive
names try to find name for variables and
functions that are you can actually
pronounce and you can also search in a
code avoid encoding admin for context
and basically don't be lazy so when you
find something that doesn't is not named
properly just rename it for that of
course you need to use a good IDE that
can discuss refactoring functions so you
can rename it once and then you don't
worry that you break in ten other places
so that's naming then functions function
is a basic building block of most
programming languages most most things
and those guys who thought hard about
clean code they rule of thumb is that
the function should be
maximum five lines long and for some
people that actually sounds quite crazy
five lines it's just too small so how do
you actually manage it but quite often
that's actually a very good thing so
maybe turn in some circumstances three
is even better so by putting small bits
of code in function then naming it
naming the function can really help
improve the ability as well as mentioned
ability and modularity then comments
sure sure yes so the question was uh
what is it what does mean have a one
level of abstraction so the same
function its but if it has for instance
data base connection layers as well as a
stats models apply to it you're kind of
mixing the two so but this is a very
kind of high level so what is a right
level of abstraction of course is
context specific but if you start
thinking oh it's actually separate
layers or is it two different things
then most likely you can separate it
into multiple functions into two
functions also some people are saying
that you should not be passing arguments
to the function that controls some if
statements
so like boolean boolean arguments that's
also a code smell in Python however it
it depends there are a lot of situations
in Python where actually it does make
sense because those advices also were
written by people who mostly Java and
C++ but I will be covering Python
specific clean code practices in in a
later section so right now we're
covering just the basics of the clean
code as it was presented and written by
Uncle Bob and other people so another
one is about comments and basically when
you feel the need to write a comment
first try to refactor the code so that
any comment becomes irrelevant generally
if you feel sorry every time you write a
comment if you write a comment you're
admitting that you can't write a code
that people can read and understand
circumstance there are exceptions of
course so if you actually found that
there is a specific bug in a library and
you need to hack around it and then you
do it in something quite and all this in
this special case you probably should
write a comment so that the next person
would not try to just refactor it and
use functionality that's supposed to
work because well you just retried and
it doesn't work or if the algorithm is
very complex and you actually do feel
that you need to explain it but in most
circumstances comments is a is a code
smell and you should try to get rid of
them
effectively when I wrote this on the gut
and I understood what I was doing now
god only knows it's one of the good
comments let's look at more examples
sometimes believe my compiler ignores
all my comments yep that's that's true I
also feel the same oh that's the best
one so yeah yes sometimes you change the
code but quite often you forget to
change comments so those comments can be
there lying around and then just be
misleading so how to get there lots of
resources out there there are lots of
good books written on the subject by
people much smarter than I'm myself and
who thought a lot about it also code
conventions is important in any
organization and as soon as the fastest
you team will arrive to some code
convention try to follow it the better
you'll be in a long run so on the team
conventions are more important than
language conventions or your personal
conventions of course so that was a
generic clean code things let's move
specifically to Python and bison is of
course not Java C++ so there are
differences first of all is called
convention code style how many of you
know pipe eight well most people do
that's great for those of you who don't
definitely check it out it might be
already outdated a bit but generally
it's still very relevant another good
resource for a style guide that you can
just adopt in your organization
don't argue too much about it is
Google title guide so they have
conventions about naming and about all
sorts of things and there are books
written specifically on how to write
clean code in Python so my favorite one
is a fluent Python but there are some
other ones as well because yes bison is
not Java and there are a few things that
so design patterns for instance in
Python and you can't just apply Java
design patterns and hope the your Python
code to be nicely written because it's
not okay so Jupiter notebooks spy data
conference so most of you are using
Jupiter most of you are doing some sort
of data science or maybe more on a
science side of things so how to apply
those principles are those principles
applicable inside Jupiter notebooks well
of course they are but there are also
differences so typical organization of a
notebook is you import your stuff then
you get your data then you do something
to your data then you maybe do some
modeling visualizations and then
concluding things and this is kind of
general pattern in a lot of data science
notebooks at them from to say all the
data science notebooks but a lot of them
follow some sort of this pattern and as
a community so the Jupiter notebook and
overall coating in notebook is
relatively new format so there is not
that many resources available not the
planet best practices are available on
how to organize a research project so
actually one of the origins of this talk
is a stack overflow question as a lot of
those talks start and somebody asked the
question how to organize a Python
notebook project when you have few
collaborators few scientists working
together on a project how to organize it
so first question that I would like to
ask not really answer is how should how
big should a notebook file will be so we
here in Berlin PI data conference a
bunch of data scientists and we should
be leading this thinking and I would
like to ask your thoughts as well so in
my experience one notebook file which
should should only try to keep a
notebook files small so one notebook
file per major hypothesis you have an
idea you test in one notebook if you
have multiple ideas it's better to split
them in different notebooks so you have
a hypothesis you get some data you
understand the data you explore data and
you either confirm the hypothesis or
denied the hypothesis so and in my
experience I like to keep my notebooks
small I'd say four maybe ten cells long
if it's more than ten cells normally
most often than not it's very hard to
follow it's very hard to read so
computer programmers software engineers
has been doing that for decades they
were splitting their long source files
into smaller files and I think as a data
scientist we should actually adopt those
practices because they're as relevant
for us as for software engineering
community so please your notebooks how
to split the notebooks in multiple ways
to do it but that's kind of one idea if
you're doing a lot of data processing
just move it into a separate notebook
the just doing only data processing and
wrangling where you combine your data
you're cleaning your data maybe even
splitting it further and then in
notebooks where you're actually
analyzing the data where you're building
some models probably should be a
separate notebook so the second chip
that is and we arrived there organically
is there are a lot of repetitions and
you kind of start seeing that people are
copy pasting code from one notebook to
another it could be your data connection
function so you always establish a
connection to the sequel database or to
whatever data you have there there was
also some publishing functions that are
quite common in organizations so we
normally work with slides with Google
flights effectively and the publishing
library that generates slides it's one
of the perfect examples of what you can
put in your shared library but also
database connections your visualization
libraries some other things that are
common but that are not specific to the
problem at hand of course so if you're
not doing that in your organization
start doing that early and then you can
reuse and you can really clean up your
notebooks so that you know
books will be just about the coach and
about your research not about those
utility stupid things that you just copy
past secondly actually ipython notebooks
is not just Python there it is specific
it's kind of it's it's a different beast
so don't put your magic source of a
notebook int into different files so if
you're fitting a model or your building
analysis that part of the stuff should
not go into utils library because when
people are opening a notebook they
expect to see that's what they want to
see they want to see the model they want
to see how you actually analyzing the
data and if when they open in notebook
and they just find that you're using a
function that you put in some Python
files that you're just importing well
they then have to go into this file and
try to figure out what's in this file
and then it's much harder to reproduce
so the secret sauce don't put an A in
your utils library sure yes so for
instance the plotting functions I kind
of sometimes you have a
multi-dimensional data most dimensional
time series in our context and quite
often you look at different variables
you're slicing and dicing and those
things you probably should put them in a
function but the secret sauce is
probably better to keep in a notebook so
you feel fit in your model I probably
rather put put it in notebook also
generally a duplication is better than
drawing abstraction and quite often we
as an engineers at least those of us who
feel that the urge to engineer sometimes
we want to abstract we want to find
those commonalities and we actually I
can put it in a function in a class
because it's I'm actually doing almost
the same things and then you figuring
out that actually I need to add those
special cases for this model and then
you start adding those boolean arguments
to your functions so that it can cover
different cases but generally first make
its work then my ca'tridge and then only
make it beautiful and small and
duplication is quite often better than
wrong abstraction
yeah Kim code reads like a well-written
prose and here let's aim for Jupiter
notebooks to be to be read like a
well-written prose so the second
question is how big a cell should be
cell the fundamental building block
energy between notebook and I argue that
each shell its cell should have one
output so what makes a notebook and
cells unique is that you write your code
and then you see an output of whatever
you just did so if you have multiple
outputs for cell probably it's not a
good idea of course there are exceptions
but basically one cells I have an idea I
execute and I see an output and that's
it so that person who is ringing reading
your notebook can much easier follow
your line of thought so if you have
multiple outputs it can be harder to it
then another tip is coming from a
test-driven development and also just
writing tests you can write a test in
Python notebooks and there is a great
plugin for pi test pie test is a unit
test runner for python one of the main
ones and so there is a plugin that
allows you to that will find tests
inside your notebook so you need your
name your notebooks tests underscore and
then whitest ronamoon them will execute
them and then will report errors later
so for instance when you're working on
the shared library that is used across
the organization you can actually write
tests inside notebooks because a lot of
those functions will be executed in a
notebook environment so why write unit
tests not a notebook environment if you
right here in tests a notebook
environment it also would be easier for
other people to read those notebooks and
then see what your functions are
supposed to do within the outputs and
everything another thing what we found
so normally when an organization just
start adopting Jupiter notebooks quite
often it starts from the ground up so
normally they designed as some of them
are kind of playing the spice and some
of them maybe complain bizarre and then
those who are using Python starts
probably putting on a corner on their
local machines
as soon as you create a shared Jupiter
server the sooner you'll get a code that
you can reproduce you can share and you
can really collaborate and it's super
important so we of course started there
everybody has their own anaconda
environment and then you fighting the
differences in libraries so I'm using
pandas version this and then I country
typical in my new pandas because I just
upgraded anaconda also while you might
have your shared library it's much
harder to make changes to the shared
library and also deploy those shared
library if it's on a server you make a
change you deploy everybody is using it
otherwise everybody has their own
versions of your shared library and then
you need to have you updated a shared
library do you know that we actually
updated it no I haven't because I'm too
busy right so the sooner you get a
shared server at the batter and the
sooner you get to Ori producible I
resolve that are easier to read I'd like
to talk about few code smells that we
discovered in our experience the first
code smell energy with a notebook the
worst one and that's what makes jupiter
notebooks actually pretty bad some
people are going as far as saying it's
horrible form atoms we should not
actually be using notebooks is if you're
not careful you can make a notebook
unreproducible right you can execute
cells in whatever order and then it can
change the state I in different places
and unfortunately as far as I know even
right now in the latest Jupiter version
restart and run all it's still a menu
item it's not a button on on on a
tooltip you can actually put it you can
make a shortcut but basically try to
make sure that you at any point in time
in your search in your analysis you can
hit restart and run all and you get to
the same results to get there you
probably need to work on the caching
layer especially if it takes some time
to load the data or manipulate the data
so in a location library the cache is
automatically created every time you
connect to database and you extract some
data so rerunning the whole notebook
should be fast and for that you need to
invest in your share tools so you can
actually rerun a notebook and it's fast
of course sometimes not possible if
you're doing a Markov chain Monte Carlo
and it takes whatever half an hour to
converge
yeah good luck was that also you can
kind of mix your ideas prototypes and
your clean clean results and clean after
yourself whisk you you played with a
coat you reached somewhere delete those
cells or make a copy of notebook before
you start cross typing so you keep your
main notebook the one that you're
actually working on and if you have this
exploratory idea make a duplicate and
work in a duplicate copy so you don't
end up with some prototype in cells
mixing together with your output cells
slightly experimental idea but actually
yesterday it was mentioned already a
pattern that is emerging and we actually
find it quite useful it's a pattern when
you run a notebook from another notebook
so quite often you work on a noble case
of an analysis and the typical way to
rerun it is of course to wrap it in a
function maybe in a class because if
your function is too big you probably
want to break it into costs but then
you're actually breaking the whole
Jupiter environment if you take the
whole research and try to put it in a
function then it would be harder to
reproduce it will be harder to read for
other data scientists you are losing
this idea execution output format that
cells provide and as an idea what you
can do you can actually put all the main
parameters main arguments for a notebook
into the first cell in a notebook and
then run one notebook from another
notebook
we found it useful it's still somewhat
experimental Fisher but quite often you
actually want to do is you don't want to
copy it paste everything into a function
you just want to run the same analysis
but with a different set of inputs
different dates different user segments
whatever it is and then apparently
yesterday I heard that there's a github
project that's already doing that but
here I'm presenting a snippet of code
that also works that's what is and then
you can actually take this idea one step
forward and then make a product directly
from your notebook so if you can run a
notebook from another notebook and then
pass parameters then actually in this
other notebook you can put a simple UI
using a brilliant eye by widgets library
and then effectively turn your notebook
into a product and then with the Jupiter
dashboards actually you can pushed one
step forward and you can easily share
this with within the organization and
kinda what we're reaching with the
solution is actually we are right now
building products we're not just playing
around with research we're actually
building products and I believe that
that's what the design is supposed to
the left foot actually differentiates
data scientists from data analysts
actually we're supposed to make our
research and knowledge easily shareable
and easily reproducible and ultimately
empowering everyone to use data
internists and data so in summary sir
with version control the version control
in jupiter notebooks is not a completely
solved problems are there are a few ways
to do it so what we do we do check the
code to github but so you push the
content of the folder to github but it's
actually in a separate folder so our
github repository isn't doesn't live on
the same level where all the notebooks
are it's actually separate so and then
we have a copy everything to get a
repository create a new branch and then
push this branch so that's how we deal
with it so everything is on a github yes
so we don't do pre-processing on top of
notebooks I know there are some projects
that try to you know strip everything
that's not a code so you can do this and
every single that we're not there yet so
we're kind of we didn't really feel that
much need to make it do that because
actually it's also great when you can go
to github open a notebook and then you
see the output as well so if you strip
out
all your output all the metadata then
inside github when you look at it it's
just just cells so then it's harder to
read
so yeah notebooks keep them small make
your make utils library good Jupiter
notebooks which reads like a well
written prose each cell should have one
and only one output write tests deploy a
shared Jupiter server try to keep code
inside notebooks avoid refraction two
modules if possible but of course if
it's your scientific code not alt code
and that's pretty much it so right now
I'd like to discuss with you
[Applause]
[Music]
I can just repeat your question so it
just so the question was about best
practices to train deploring networks
let's talk about Jupiter notebooks not
really about declaring so I'm sorry but
not really but yeah you can of course
use I think like most examples about
deep learning they are actually in a
notebook format why notebook format is
specific to what like deep learning is a
special case yeah that's that's that's
what we actually did so so remark was
was it better to deploy a GPS server
with a notebook with a Jupiter on the
GPU server and then have people access
to it so and that's actually watch what
we did so we created a c2 instance that
you can normally shut down because you
know GPU instance are not cheap and
normally we don't actually need GPU
instance but if you do you go to the c2
you resurrect it so it's running and
then you connect to Jupiter on the GPU
instance and then you can use the GPU
instance and then you stop it so that
you stop paying yeah that's definitely a
possibility
thank you for the talk I totally agree
with pretty much everything is except
point 7 I really think you should keep
almost all implementation out of Jupiter
notebooks because then if I read someone
else's stupid a notebook I have to go
through all the implementation of
everything which I don't care about as
long as the function has a name that I
understand I know what's happening but
yeah my question is I really like the UI
builder thing that you shown I haven't
seen that before
can you elaborate a bit more on how you
use it and if there's maybe a way to
hide the cells because I feel like for
non-technical people it's very
intimidating if you have all the code in
there as well so the question actually
there was a microphone yes so the UI is
of course built using ipython widgets a
well-known library it's great so how to
hide code and how to make it kind of
more presentable and more student and
user friendly
we started by injecting a small
JavaScript snippet that would just hide
ourselves that was version one quite
ugly implementation and then the problem
of course is that somebody will still
open your notebook and it's kind of one
instance so if two users start using a
notebook
they of course start stepping on each
other's toes and it's not good but there
is a great project called Jupiter
dashboards that makes deploying
application from Jupiter notebook as
simple as just clicking
you eye item and then selecting deploy
as as a web application and what it does
copies your Python notebook file to
normally to a different container and
then people would connect to that and
then there is a kernel manager that
would create new kernels every time the
user which would connect it so that's of
course superior solution because it's a
proper web app there's no cell so you
don't also don't worry that somebody
will actually mess around with your
notebook
who else has questions just so I can
spread them equally along the room not
just nailed me okay let's go to someone
there and when we'll come back here
anyone else in the room just a quick
follow-up you can actually in the
dashboard server like rearrange all your
widgets and stuff like you have a
layouting engine which is like very very
nice and you can get rid of the code and
it looks really cool like it's it's so
much better than just like writing a web
app on top of your analysis yeah then
another point there's like a cool cookie
cutter project the data science cookie
cutter project which gives it like a
nice folder structure for your iPad
notebook so you have a make file which
downloads all the files that you need
and stuff and it makes everything like
more reproducible just check that out
it's a great tool
I forgot my extra question sorry okay I
have one have you looked into tepelini
looks and like digit compare them
whereas a typewriter notebook on not
seriously so we considered them for SQL
only because you can just write SQL
without any Python code and then plot it
without any plotting code so for that
reason we looked at yeah just before
people start leaving the room I want to
make a final remark if you haven't
learned anything from this presentation
because everything was obvious to you
and you're kind of doing it already I
really want to talk to you because what
guy is hiring if you have listened to
this talk and you learn something and
actually you want to do more of that
then I want to talk to you because
Google is hiring if you listen to the
presentation and didn't learn anything
because you're not interested in that
then okay is still hiring but maybe I'm
not so interested talking to you
ok I have a question 1 do you see that
super notebooks are not good to be used
I'm sorry when we should not use Jupiter
notebooks when you should not use yeah
we need case where yeah of course well I
think if you're working on complex
application with multiple you know
dependencies I would much prefer to work
inside a PyCharm environment that's idea
of my choice and she knows your Emacs
user or Winnie users sucking up to you
but I like her to work inside ID and at
this point a Jupiter ID is definitely
far from perfect so only a couple of
less than two years ago they introduced
search and replace all functionality
before that you couldn't even do that
and there is no refactoring
functionality in Jupiter notebooks you
can't just you know appropriately rename
the variable or class and have a renamer
that is context sided context specific
and understand that you don't just want
to do a dummy search and replace but you
actually replace never idle there is no
refactoring functions to extract a part
of the function or methods into a sub
function so I would always prefer to
work inside pycharm of with code
compared to notebooks but from the other
hand I really like that you can run a
bit of code and then you see an output
and then you can move on and you do that
and that I think that's super fast it's
super useful and yeah question anyone
know one - thanks for the talk very
interesting and I actually learned
something that is calling a notebook
from another notebook but I would like
to know if you have any example where
this is useful sure so a for instance
arm we do a lot of cohorts and also user
behavior notes so we might be looking at
how users in a specific game who
installed a game in January this year
behaved since since today basically how
their you use a journey evolved and you
work on the results and it's all fine
and then um you want to actually maybe
maybe you want to look at different
cohort and
then you can run the whole analysis with
all the steps all your visualizations
all the modeling but just on different
cohort or users or on a different game
so that's an example we also say let's
take the let's take the final question
offline oh you can you can ask but we
get that yeah it's kind of quick yet so
for the basically Jupiter and cloud I
was using that with colleagues and we
ran into problems because basically when
two people work in the same notebook
it's not gonna really work out what is
the best practice there it can be a
problem so the alternative is to
actually have a dedicated local
containers for environments I'm actually
against that I think that it's not too
hard to develop some sort of a
convention of if you're opening a
notebook that is already running because
when you open you can see a green icon
it means that somebody is working on it
so you duplicate a notebook and then you
can if you think that you will actually
do something that's of course quite ugly
and you know duplication or however
normally it works and actually if you
keep your notebook small that to large
degree solves this problem because the
reason why you want to work on the same
notebook if you're working on same on
research but probably you can split it
into some small notebooks and therefore
you wouldn't be really stepping on each
other's toes so keep your notebook small
and don't over complicate things it
works
[Applause]